Our first solution to this problem is that we
don't do out of order load/store execution, instead we
do in order load/store execution. This is what happens
in that case. The load is a miss, the add
is stalled, the store is stalled because of that,
because they're both, both waiting for the load to eventually
finish. The subtraction gets done. We now know the
address for this load. At that point in the load/store
queue, we will check whether there are any preceding instructions
that might eventually resolve to the same address. Or even worse,
we check whether there is just all preceding instructions are done.
Because this load is not done, we are not going to consider
this store for execution, that is for producing the value for
this address, and as a result, we are also not going to
do this load. So pretty much what now happens is this
load here doesn't go to memory although it knows where the
address is. Eventually this mess is resolved.
We compute R7 and then very quickly afterwards
we are going to compute the address for the store. So now what we have is,
this load gets done. This instruction was
already done. Eventually, the add gets done, and
eventually the store gets done. The store is
considered done, not when it commits, but when
it actually knows the address, and knows the value that is
going to go to that address. At that point only, this load
is allowed to proceed because at that point, it can just go
up and check whether any stores produced the values for the address
that we are interested in, and if so, just grab the
value. So the load can only finish after the store has finished.
And the store will not do anything until this load is done,
et cetera. So really, we are executing most of the instructions out
of order here. But loads and stores are still proceeding in
order. Of course you can see that this is suboptimal if
this store doesn't store to the same address. We have been
waiting here for a very time and thus we have delayed
all of the instructions that depend on the load. Worse, if
the load would have been a cache miss. We were sitting
there not trying to order things from memory, until many many
cycles later potentially, and only then we realize we have a cache
miss and have to wait many many cycles more. So this is of
course not a very high performance solution, but it is a correct solution.